Katy Perry and Zedd big night here at
the iHeartRadio Music Awards they're
presenting the very very first award but
the reason they're together they have
365 out their new song is unbelievable
but I've got bad news for you that isn't
really Katy Perry no it's not tell them
who you are
well I am Katy Perry today but I am an
AI version of Katy Perry what is AI
version of Katy Perry do well it's an
unfortunate date because today is Pi Day
and it's a very dangerous day because if
you tell an AI to calculate pi they end
up never stopping and they die low-end
robots take over the world that's how
you win the war okay guys we talk a lot
I know I carried it over the question
now go it's all you we love 365 so much
we're so excited to get new music from
you but here's the thing Taylor Swift
was just on this carpet before you what
about the rumors that Katy Perry and
Taylor Swift could make music together I
mean I'm making music with Zedd I'm open
open open open does that mean yeah her
to make music with anybody is great
choice we loved that video of you in
Orlando watching Idol together how happy
are you girl we are so happy for you I
mean what made him you know that he was
the one for you oh thank you very much
it's just obvious
[Music]